Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today is going to be all about turbulence! And we
are going to do this, and this, and this and…this.
To understand what this new paper has to offer,
we have to look at an earlier work named Wavelet
Turbulence. Apart from the fact that it in
my opinion, it is one of the best papers ever
written, it could do one thing extremely well.
In goes a coarse, low-resolution smoke or fluid
simulation, and out comes a proper simulation
with a lot more details. And, it is typically
accurate enough to fool us. And all this was
possible in 2008. Kind of boggles the mind,
so much so, that this work even won a technical
Oscar award. Please remember this accuracy
statement as it will matter a great deal.
Once again, accurate enough to fool us.
Now, more than a decade later, here we are,
this new method is leaps and bounds better,
and can do 5 amazing things that
the previous methods couldn’t do.
One, it can do spatiotemporal upsampling.
Upsampling both in space and in time.
What does this mean? It means that in
goes a choppy, low resolution simulation,
and out comes a smooth, detailed simulation.
Wow, now that is incredible. It is really able
to fill in the information not only
in space, but in time too. So good.
Now, two, previous methods typically try to take
this coarse input simulation and add something
to it. But not this new one. This new method
creates a fundamentally new simulation from it.
Just look here. It didn’t just add a few
more details to the input simulation,
this is a completely new work.
That is quite a difference.
Three, I mentioned that Wavelet Turbulence
was accurate enough to fool us. So I wonder
how accurate this new method is? Well, that’s
what we are here for, so…let’s see together!
Here comes the choppy input simulation, and here
is an upsampling technique from a bit more than
a year ago. Well, better, yes, but the output is
not smooth, I could characterize it more as less
choppy. And, let’s see the new method. Can it do
any better? My goodness. Look at that! That is a
smooth and creamy animation with tons of details.
Now, let’s pop the question - how does it compare
to the reference simulation - reality if you will?
What? I cannot believe my eyes. I can’t tell the
difference at all! So this new technique is
not just accurate enough to fool the human eye,
this is accurate enough to stand up to
the real, high-resolution simulation.
And all this improvement in just
one year. What a time to be alive!
But wait a second. Does this even make sense?
If we have the real reference simulation here,
why do we need the upsampling technique? Why
not just use the reference? Well, it makes
sense - the plan is that we only need to compute
the cheap coarse simulation, upsample it quickly,
and hope that it is as good as the reference
simulation, which takes a great deal longer.
Well, okay, but how much longer? Now, hold on
to your papers, and let’s see the results, and….
yes! This is about 5 to 8 times faster than
creating the high-resolution simulation we
compared to, which is absolutely amazing,
especially that it was created with a modern,
blazing fast reference simulator
that runs on your graphics card.
But, remember, I promised you five advantages, not
three. So, what are the remaining two? Well, four,
it can perform compression! Meaning
that the output simulation will take
up to 600 times less data on our disk, that is
insanity. So, how much worse is the simulation
stored this way? My goodness, look at that! It
looks nearly the same as the original one. Wow.
And, we are still not done yet.
Not even close! Five. It also works on super
high Reynolds numbers. In other words, if we have
some of the more difficult cases
where there is tons of turbulence,
it will works really well. This typically
gives a lot of troubles to previous techniques.
Now, one more important thing. Views are, of
course, not everything. However, I couldn’t
not notice that this work was only seen by
127 people. Yes. I am not kidding. 127 people.
This is why I am worried that if we don’t
talk about it here on Two Minute Papers,
almost no one will talk about it. And
these works are so good, people have
to know! Thank you very much for watching
this, and let’s spread the word together!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!